Dave what was the Tipping Point for you
to leave California like if you were to
say well the Tipping Point was five
years ago but I finally made a decision
today or was it like covet I'm done I'm
sick of it let's start looking at
different places and then you looked at
Tennessee Texas and Florida and you said
I'm going to go to Florida yeah so I
moved to LA in 2013. uh we had about a
thousand bucks from New York from New
York so I'm a true New Yorker born in
Brooklyn grew up in Long Island I went
to SUNY Binghamton I lived in Manhattan
most of my life so really the only two
places as an adult that I've lived until
these last three months were New York
City and LA and yet the ideas that I
talk about are the stuff that people
care about in the middle of the country
so I don't know what happened I don't
know what happened I had these two
coasts and somehow my ideas kind of kind
of came to them when you moved from New
York to L.A did you come with that New
York you know Coastal ideology to oh
yeah I was I was Lefty I worked for The
Young Turks I was a Bernie supporter all
of that all that all that stuff it's all
it's true all of it as uh Han Solo said
yeah it was all true
um but there were a couple moments I
mean look the the two years of covid
demolished Los Angeles Los Angeles is a
shell of itself Hollywood has been
destroyed okay so I could do all the
basic stuff the climb the homeless is
the drug but I'll tell you what the
final moment was the final straw and I
had been thinking about it for about a
year back and forth could I do it where
was I going to go Nashville Dallas
Etc uh I campaigned with Larry Elder for
the for the recall so I was opening on
stage with him and talk you know going
out there and meeting people and it was
amazing it was incredible you know they
called him the black face of white
supremacy that's what the L.A nine times
article yeah which I felt like an onion
headline by the way or a baby
even that good a young woman who threw
an egg at him in the gorilla mask that
always I thought somehow the media
didn't pick that one up you know it's
like it was just extraordinary anyway
I'm out there with this guy and there
was such energy I met so many good
people they were not far right they
weren't even conservatives most of them
were liberals they were California
liberals who were mugged by reality they
were just good decent people who
suddenly their restaurants were closed
their kids were locked down all of this
stuff anyway the recall obviously was a
disaster and three days after the recall
do you want the exact moment your mind
is going to explode three days after the
recall I got audited by the state hahaha
that makes sense yeah and I said we have
you ever been audited before I've never
been audited before my my stuff's all
cleaned it was all fine uh we take very
good care of all all my businesses
um three days after got that immediately
like literally I think I hung up the
phone and I called my real estate agent
I said get me out of here and we put
that we did the house privately
well I was told in three weeks basically
and then I had to really quickly figure
out I always felt that it was going to
be Florida uh but you know I loved the
The Blaze guys and I do some stuff with
them and Glenn Beck and Glenn really
wanted me in Dallas so I had a little
moment of that I love the daily wire
guys and Candace and Ben and so I did
look at one house in Nashville but I am
so happy to be here and I'm I'm really
like as I said I'm born here I feel you
feel it here in Florida it's free you
said something prior to shooting you
said I love Florida you could curse if
you want yeah there was an F in there
yeah no I I F in love Florida it's it's
not just
it's not just the the politics of it
that that's good it's what it's doing to
the people uh you know I don't know when
the last time you guys just went back to
New York or went to Cali or just went to
some of these blue cities he's from Cali
yeah yeah no I know so but I don't know
have you been there just in the last
couple months like I went to LA to shoot
a prageru video about a month ago I said
to my guys I will fly in go to the
studio and get me the hell out of there
even though the prageru studio is a half
mile from my house I guess it would have
been nice to go look at it again or
something it was a disaster I got asked
for a vaccine passport to go to Coffee
Bean and Tea Leaf uh that makes sense
just everything about it it's rotten and
then even just the greenery The Greenery
in Florida is beautiful and wonderful in
the trees and then you go to La and
everything's dying and dead and brown
it's uh what the hell am I being clear
about this uh yeah I'm very happy here I
don't like that place but by the way
what was the reason why you chose
Florida over Dallas and uh Nashville you
know it's partly I think because of my
well first off I have some family here
and we hadn't had I've been in a state
with family for a long time most I'm
from New York as I said so most of my
family's East Coast my folks have a
place in Florida my sister lives in
Miami with her husband and kids uh also
because of the tech side of things
obviously Miami is just exploding right
now in the tech world so I wanted to be
close to that but at a political level
you know for me as someone that came
from the left and you know I have mostly
libertarian views but I don't mind
calling myself a conservative now
there's a wide thing right hat right now
happening on the right you know you got
the disaffected lefties and the
Libertarians then you've got the you
know sort of Evangelical or the
Christian conservatives there really is
this movement of trying to figure out
can this thing really hold because there
are a lot of people that have different
beliefs serious beliefs that are very
different I felt the the stuff that I
care about the most it's working here in
Florida meaning it's a little more of a
secular conservatism as opposed to you
go to Nashville or you go to Texas it's
a little more religious that's not
necessarily my thing I felt that the
ideas that I really care about can
flourish a little bit more here so it
was it was a series of things you know
the weather is good and all that stuff
tell him with the reasons you wanted to
go to Florida he was from L.A he was in
Dallas I mean he's got some very good
jobs listen I knew we were moving out of
La in 2012 2013 when he moved to Plano
and he moved to Plano says it was
beautiful yeah so he says you got to
start looking into Texas I'm also a
California Refugee I came in 13 to Texas
yeah and look at us yeah look at us now
I came I came to Florida in 1980 guys so
when he was born here nice try fella no
but yeah but you know so at that time I
started looking at everything but being
Middle Eastern everybody it's tough to
leave your family mom dad sister friends
restaurants things your cab went to
Glendale High School so do I want to
leave this you know relationships I got
and I started looking I said nope I
cannot build an insurance company being
headquartered out of California no way
in the world so I looked at Central for
me it was important to go to Texas
because I travel a lot we have a couple
hundred 150 offices Nation why so if I'm
going to La three hours three hours
three hours three hours Florida would
have been six and back in the time
difference La would have been six and
back in time difference so Dallas made
the most most sense because I was
traveling a ton if somebody's building a
national business I don't think Florida
or California makes sense I think the
best spot to be in is a Dallas is a
Houston it's in Austin if you travel a
ton and then so we moved to Houston we
moved to Dallas we lived in Plano for a
few years and then we were right by
Addison our headquarters was in Addison
and then gradually when covet hit I
started looking I said we gotta look at
Tennessee
Nashville I lived in Tennessee for two
years when I was in the Army and I said
where are they going to stay here in
Dallas but then I love the water I love
the water the ocean California I mean I
just love that right and I said listen
if California and Texas had a baby it
would be Florida so I said that was the
best combination to come to Florida and
we've been here now for what 14 months
13 months 14 months and I'm in love just
as much as you are I got to tell you so
people always say to me is there
anything you don't like I honestly
cannot think of anything yes I could
complain about the traffic a little bit
but I lived in New York and L.A so no
I'm not gonna is there anything anything
so okay let's let's do it let's be okay
we haven't really experienced a
hurricane yet okay so I don't know what
a hurricane looks like I've been through
tornado I've been through Wars I've been
through earthquakes yeah okay we'll see
what the at least hurricane gives you a
warning earthquake does not tornadoes
don't give you too much of a warning
hurricane you know for two or three days
that something's coming right plus it
was raining fire in L.A yeah come on
yeah literally well Dave I'm gonna
iguanas are not vicious but I want to
revisit this exact conversation in
August in August and September I get it
myself is gonna be a little flattered
Dave I get it okay so if they're nine
months out of the Year this is the best
place to be in the world period full
stop yeah three months out of the year
go anywhere else that's my opinion so
every summer I would travel I was here
for that and it's hot as hell here it
did not bother me when I was here oh
you're from Iran yeah it's a good point
right there you know I'm at a party with
Pat it was last year at the Bitcoin
conference uh it was in June last year
and it was hot out we were at that party
Outdoors people are sweating Pat's
wearing a jacket I'm like this guy can
withstand anything it's chilly exactly
yeah you want to take the jacket out Pat
I'm good so if you could stand the heat
like with anything but forget about the
weather what was that conference about
that was about a mayor of a major United
States city coming out and in favor of
crypto and trying to attract uh
innovators and entrepreneurs to come to
us to come to a city shout out to
someone so forget about the exactly
mayor Suarez is another reason that
Florida is so wonderful I grew up here I
had I had about four years here in high
school my dad's job moved us here but I
was born and raised in California
basically and we were here there was a
republican governor his name was Bob
Graham but if you take a look at like a
one to ten and a tennisbury gold water
and a one is Bernie Bob Graham was like
exactly a five and he was trying to
build jobs he was trying to be not so
tourist and transitory you know the
snowbirds and so the seeds of this went
Florida I think go back to 1980 and
there was guys like Charlie Crist and
now DeSantis that have been faithful to
it and they haven't screwed it up by
trying to go way one way or the other
and I think that's one of the benefits
and then a Suarez Rises up fantastic
Hispanic mayor representing every kid
that can wake up in Miami in the morning
and say I could be mayor I could be
mayor look at that you know I was at an
event last night at Keith Urban boy's
house and you know Keith was the one
that originally sent the tweet that
Suarez responded how can I help which
basically caused the influx I mean I
would say part part of the reason I'm
here is because of that so I was at this
event at reboy's last night and Suarez
was there and he gave a talk and I'm
standing there watching the guy and I've
met him a couple times I interviewed him
once and I'm thinking man this is so the
reverse 180 reverse of what I was
dealing with in L.A Eric Garcetti was
destroying actively destroying and we
can go okay what were the intentions
good or not that that's an interesting
conversation I don't think the
intentions are good actually I think
they are intentionally doing this stuff
but I'm listening to Suarez he's talking
about how they want to be this
International City that will be the Hub
of crypto and the new economy and they
want to be 30 years ahead of America
when it comes to all of this other stuff
and because the federal government is so
screwy we just have to do what we think
is right and then last week I did a
prageru event where where uh DeSantis
spoke and all DeSantis says is basic
honesty it's not that he's out there
saying the most crazy stuff that's
riling people up in reality he's
basically saying honest decent stuff
which is revolutionary in 2022 and it's
just such a stark difference man so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]